nous avons l'honneur d'accueillir
monsieur Clément bonne ministre délégué
auprès du ministre de la transition
écologique et de la cohésion des
territoires chargés des transports
monsieur mise je vous souhaite la
bienvenue je vous remercie de vous être
rendu disponible pour répondre à nos
questions aujourd'hui vous le savez à
partir du 10 juillet 2022 plusieurs
membres du consortium international des
journalistes d'investigation ont publié
ce qui les désormais convenu d'appeler
les hubert-files s'appuyant sur 124000
documents internes à l'entreprise
américaine d'été de 2013 à 2017 cette
enquête a dénoncé les méthodes de
lobbying c'était uber pour implanter en
France comme dans de nombreux pays des
véhicules de transport et chauffeurs des
VTC dans concurrencer le secteurs
traditionnel du transport public
particulier de personnes réservées
jusqu'alors au taxi dans ce contexte
notre commission d'enquête à deux
objectifs d'une part identifié
l'ensemble des actions de lobbying
menées par uber pour pouvoir s'implanter
en France le rôle des décideurs publics
de l'époque et mettre des
recommandations concernant l'encadrement
des relations entre décideurs publics et
représentants d'intérêt
d'autre part pour ambition d'évaluer les
conséquences économiques sociales
environnementales du développement du
modèle uber l'ubérisation en France et
les réponses apportées et à apporter par
les décideurs publics en la matière dans
ce cadre nous avons été largement
interpellé sur l'évolution de la
concurrence la réglementation entre les
taxis et les VTC depuis l'émergence des
plateformes numériques telles qu'uber en
2013 malgré le lobbying du beurre
vis-à-vis des décideurs publics de
l'époque de tout bord pour imposer son
modèle la réglementation a
systématiquement évolué pour permettre
la coexistence pacifiée entre les taxis
et les VTC et l'encadrement de ces
nouvelles pratiques d'abord avec
l'adoption de la proposition de loi
thévenou puis celle à l'initiative de
Laurent grand-guillaume près de 10 ans
plus tard quel bilan faites-vous de
l'évolution de la concurrence entre les
différents acteurs de l'application de
la réglementation en vigueur dans le
secteur du transport public particulier
de personnes en France il nous a
beaucoup été indiqué au cours de ces
auditions que avant l'arrivée de ces
acteurs et l'évolution de la
réglementation il y avait une
insuffisance au fond de l'offre à Paris
notamment mais en France comparé aux
autres capitales comparables quel bilan
faites-vous et quel regard portez-vous
aujourd'hui sur l'offre de transport
public particulier de personnes à Paris
et en France comparé au marché
européen et énormément
notre commission d'enquête notamment
constaté un manque de données
pertinentes parfois pour comprendre
l'évolution du marché de la maraude
réserveau taxi et celui de la
réservation préalable sur lequel taxi
est VTC sont en concurrence pouvez-vous
expliquer ces situations disposez-vous
des données qui vous paraissent
suffisantes pour pouvoir exercer votre
autorité sur ce secteur sur le plan
environnemental j'ai noté que le
ministère des Transports a fait de la
décarbonation du secteur une priorité
dans ce cas nous aimerons savoir quel
est l'impact du développement des VTC la
livraison sur les émotions polluantes du
secteur des transports et vous en fait
un axe de votre action sur le plan
social nous avons relevé que le
ministère des Transports assure avec le
ministère du travail que nous venons
d'auditionner la tutelle de l'ARPE
l'autorité des relations sociales des
plateformes d'emploi créée en avril 2021
pour réguler les relations sociales
entre plateforme de mobilité et
travailleurs vous pouvez nous indiquer
de quelle manière le mystère procède
pour assurer cette tutelle et quel bilan
vous tirez des premiers accords
notamment conclus au sein de l'ARPE
enfin le projet directive européenne
relative à l'amélioration des conditions
de travail via les plateformes vous
paraît-elle de nature à renforcer
l'existence d'une concurrence celle
d'enfossé entre les taxis et les VTC
quel serait les conséquences sur le
secteur du t3p de l'instauration d'une
présomption de salariat tel que souhaité
par le Parlement européen est-ce que
vous pouvez nous expliquer la position
de la France sur le débat sur cette
directive qui est en cours de discussion
dans le trilogue nous aurons bien sûr
d'autres questions à vous poser mes
collègues je vous propose d'entamer nos
discussions à ce stade je rappelle que
cette audition est ouverte à la presse
qu'elle est retransmise en direct sur le
site de l'Assemblée nationale et avant
de vous laisser la parole je vous
rappelle monsieur le ministre que leur
article 6 de l'ordonnance du 17 novembre
1958 relative au fonctionnement des
assemblées parlementaires un peu aux
personnes auditionnées par une
commission en quête de prêter serment de
dire la vérité toute la vérité rien que
la vérité je vais donc vous inviter à
lever la main droite activer votre micro
et dire je le jure
je le jure merci je vous laisse la
parole monsieur le ministre
merci beaucoup monsieur le Président et
Madame la rapporteur mesdames et
messieurs les députés merci de me donner
cette occasion en d'essayer de répondre
le plus précisément possible aux
questions de fond que vous avez soulevé
comme vous le savez je suis dans la
responsabilité de ministre délégué sur
les transports depuis un peu moins d'un
an et donc je ne saurais m'exprimé sur
l'ensemble des épisodes précédents mais
il y a évidemment depuis notamment 2014
le vote successif de de loi une
ordonnance qui a été prise en 2021 sur
la question de la régulation sociale en
particulier un cadre qui s'est déployé
pour réguler notamment ses véhicules de
transport avec chauffeur les VTC et
organiser les relations avec la
profession de taxi je m'inscris dans une
relative continuité j'y reviendrai car
je pense que par petite touche un
équilibre a été trouvé dans cette
régulation et que c'est maintenant
essentiellement sur le plan social que
nous devons faire des progrès je
reviendrai aussi sur la question
environnementale sur laquelle vous
m'avez interrogé et puis si vous le
permettez rapidement de dire un mot car
je crois que c'est cohérent avec cette
approche des sujets d'accessibilité qui
sont aussi une des grandes
transformations de ce secteur pour
donner quelques rapides éléments de
bilan et je me tiendrai évidemment à la
disposition de votre commission pour les
préciser sur l'impact de l'ouverture de
ce secteur qui ne touche pas que la
France évidemment puisque le
développement des VTC comme on les
appelle dans notre droit est une
tendance européenne et mondiale dans
toutes les économies développées liées
au développement d'applications
numériques depuis le milieu des années
2010 à peu près aujourd'hui sur le volet
de l'emploi ce sont environ 40 000 de
choses 40 000 chauffeurs de VTC qui sont
dit actifs c'est aux informations dont
nous disposons actifs dans le sens où il
y a beaucoup plus de cartes
professionnelles qui sont délivrées
environ 100 000 à la fin de l'année 2022
mais les chauffeurs qui ont une activité
régulière sont estimées par nos services
et ceux du ministère du Travail à
environ 4000 qui ont des revenus 40 000
pardon qui ont des revenus
principaux ou complémentaires liés à
cette activité je le dis très clairement
mon appréciation c'est que cette ce
développement c'est montrer bénéfique
car il a renforcé l'offre il n'a pas eu
d'effet en tout cas rien ne le démontre
au contraire de substitution ou
d'éviction par rapport à la profession
de taxi quand on regarde dans quelques
ordres de grandeur très rapides
l'évolution depuis 2014 2015 et
l'arrivée de ses services de VTC on a
aujourd'hui 100000 cartes je le disais
40 000 chauffeurs recensés comme actifs
et à côté de cela le nombre de taxis a
aussi évolué au niveau national à la
hausse atteignant à peu près 60 000
aujourd'hui quand on regarde cette
proportion 60 000 chauffeurs de taxi sur
le territoire national 40
000 chauffeurs de VTC actif on voit que
c'est un quasi doublement de l'offre de
t3p de transport public particulier de
personnes qui a été permis et pour faire
le lien également avec la question
environnementale rien n'indique même au
contraire quand on regarde les
développements respectifs des modes de
transport que cela se serait fait au
détriment ou là aussi par effet
d'éviction sur les transports publics
collectifs que nous devons évidemment je
ne rentrerai pas dans le détail de toute
la politique des transports je crois que
ça n'est pas l'objet mais développer
absolument en priorité donc dans nos
villes cela a apporté des solutions de
transport complémentaires quand nous
regardons d'ailleurs la comparaison de
notre capital vous m'avez invité avec
les grandes agglomérations et métropoles
européennes et mondiales il y a une
offre qui est à peu près 4 fois
supérieure en équivalent t3p et
notamment sur les VTC l'équivalent des
VTC dans une de capital comme Londres ou
dans une capitale comme New York qui
sont aussi des grandes
métropoles touristiques internationales
pour prendre des exemples comparables on
le sait nous avons un nombre
d'autorisation stationnement comme on
dit pour les taxis qui est faible à
Paris en particulier par rapport aux
grandes capitales internationales donc
les VTC ont aussi apporté un complément
je crois
utile dans ce système de transport
complémentaire alors où en est-on de la
régulation je ne reviendrai pas sur les
différentes étapes je sais que vous avez
déjà effectué un grand nombre
d'auditions je ne reviendrai pas donc
sur le détail de la loi de thévenou de
la loi grand Guillaume de l'ordonnance
qui a été prise par le gouvernement
précédent et confirmé par une loi de
début 2022 notamment sur cet aspect de
régulation sociale ou par la loi
d'orientation des mobilités mais si je
regarde les sujets sur lesquels nous
devons renforcer notre action j'envoie
deux principaux d'abord et cela relève
en partie de mes services ceux du
ministre à l'intérieur la lutte contre
la fraude il y a des commissions locales
départementales du t3p qui prolonce un
certain nombre de sanctions qui sont à
quelques unités par an il faut être tout
à fait honnête alors cela peut vouloir
dire qu'il y a peu de dérives par
rapport à peut-être cela veut dire aussi
que les procédures de sanction doivent
être mieux connues mieux appliqués ou
améliorer je suis prêt à regarder
notamment sur la base peut-être des
travaux de votre commission comment
renforcer cette lutte contre la fraude
cela nécessite aussi une action des
services en particulier de la préfecture
de police dans le périmètre de Paris de
la petite couronne et le préfet de
police Laurent Lounès et déterminé à
renforcer non seulement les actions mais
aussi les effectifs de ce qu'on appelle
familièrement les Bauer qui font toute
une série de contrôles sur le respect
d'obligation légale ou réglementaire
mise à disposition d'un terminal de
paiement électronique évidemment
l'absence totale de discrimination le
respect des compteurs etc et donc là je
crois qu'il y a des actions qui sont
déjà puissantes et que nous renforcerons
dans les semaines et les mois qui
viennent notamment mais c'est une
occasion et cela durera au-delà à
l'occasion donc des Jeux olympiques et
paralympiques que notre capital
accueille l'année prochaine et puis le
volet central c'est la question des
droits sociaux
et là il y a
les suivis avant l'être mise sur les
transports en partie comme ministre
chargé des affaires européennes une
action nationale et européenne qui est
importante sur l'action nationale je
suppose que mon collègue Olivier bussocq
la détaillait que la première ministre
Elisabeth borne que vous additionnez et
qui a exercé la responsabilité de Michel
chargé de transport et du travail
détaillera mieux que moi mais nous le
savons nous avons mis en place
progressivement un cadre social Haddock
qui permet de négociations sociales dans
le secteur qui a permis un certain
nombre de garanties droits sociaux les
cotisations notamment en matière de
d'accidents du travail depuis la loi de
2016 et puisque moi m'interroger
spécifiquement sur ce point et que cet
établissement public est sous la
cotutelle de mon ministère la mise en
place en effet de l'ARPE de l'autorité
des relations sociales pour les
plateformes d'emploi il y a des accords
qui ont déjà abouti avec Olivier du
socle nous étions rendu conjointement au
siège de l'ARPE avec les les
organisations des plateformes et des
chauffeurs pour consacrer si je puis
dire l'accord qui avait été trouvé sur
une rémunération minimale par course un
revenu minimum parcours de 7,65 euros
qui est une étape et nous l'avons dit
une simple première étape une étape
importante et pour répondre directement
à la question mon sentiment et que ce
cadre social commence à produire ses
effets quand nous regardons les
différents paramètres que toute
participation par exemple à l'équivalent
des élections professionnelles il est
faible c'est vrai mais ce fut une
première élection et quand on compare à
des très petites entreprises par exemple
ou le taux ne dépasse pas aux guerres
plus de 5%, nous avons des taux de
participation certes faibles mais qui
vont s'accroître j'en suis convaincu qui
seront mieux connus qui sont cohérents
avec un secteur qui est encore très
fragmenté et assez nouveau et cohérent
malheureusement si je puis dire avec une
faible participation dans beaucoup de
petites structures donc c'est une étape
qui a permis des avancées sociales il y
a un accord de méthodes qui était conclu
au même moment en début d'année qui
permet aussi des discussions
complémentaires et la presse en effet
l'écho ces derniers jours il y a des
discussions en cours sur la question des
revenus minimum pour aller au-delà de
l'accord de janvier 2023 sur l'échelon
européen
il y a un débat important qui est ouvert
qui relève davantage du ministère du
Travail que du ministère des Transports
mais je veux en dire un mot l'ayant
connu ce que je dois vous dire toutes
les informations que je connais comme
ministre chargé des affaires européennes
je tiens à le préciser à le rappeler et
je crois que la Commission européenne
peut en témoigner que les députés
européens peuvent en témoigner c'est la
France qui est à l'initiative de
l'existence d'une proposition de
directive européenne le témoigner dans
mes échanges avec le commissaire à
l'emploi qui est encore en fonction
monsieur Schmitt quand j'étais
secrétaire d'État aux Affaires
européennes j'ai vérifié mon agenda je
l'ai rencontré pour la première fois peu
de temps après être arrivé en fonction
des septembre 2020 bien avant la
présidence française de l'Union
européenne qui en avait fait un axe
important nous avons demandé qu'il y ait
un texte pas seulement les
recommandations des lignes directrices
comme on fait parfois niveau père mais
un texte juridique qui apporte une
régulation à l'échelon européen pour
plusieurs raisons pour la première
raison qui est d'apporter des garanties
sociales importantes de le faire à
l'échelon européen parce qu'on voit bien
que tous les pays sont confrontés au
même défi et que en l'absence de règles
communes il y a des règles très
différentes ce qui se comparent les unes
aux autres plus ou moins bien et puis il
y a une action qui a apporté des
protections sociales réelles en justice
mais des décisions parfois éparses qui
ne décident pas un cadre social garanti
lisible protecteur et c'est le sens de
cette demande que nous avons portée au
niveau européen
et ensuite la Commission européenne a
effectuée un certain nombre de
consultations proposer un texte qui
repose comme vous le savez sur l'idée
d'une présomption de salariat et pour
être transparent jusqu'au bout c'était à
la fois la France qui a demandé qui
était une directive et un texte européen
et la solution que nous avons préconisée
comme quoi la Commission européenne a
écouté plus largement alors qu'elle
était au départ réticente à lui-même
d'un texte c'était de garder la même
logique qu'au niveau national
c'est-à-dire définir un cadre Haddock et
de ne pas plaquer à 100% le modèle du
salariat sur une activité nouvelle et
sur une activité j'insiste aussi qui est
très diversifiée on parle beaucoup des
chauffeurs et des livreurs à juste titre
mais il y a toute une série d'autres
activités
d'organisation événementielle de
prestation informatique etc qui ne sont
d'ailleurs pas fous pas toujours des
activités mal rémunérées ou peu
qualifiés donc il y a une très grande
diversité de plateforme notamment en
France et partout en Europe et donc
notre conviction profonde a toujours été
de dire qu'il était préférable c'est un
débat qui est très préférable d'avoir un
cadre social la doc pour protéger les
vrais indépendants
et sanctionner les employeurs de fait le
faux indépendants mais gardez cet
équilibre entre les deux car quand on
interroge un certain nombre de
plateformes comme j'avais fait à
l'époque où j'étais secrétaire d'État
aux Affaires européennes beaucoup disent
nous voulons garder une indépendance une
autonomie mais avec les droits sociaux
renforcés et donc cette troisième voie
si je peux le dire ainsi que nous avons
défendu en France très en avance sur
beaucoup de pays nous l'avons porté au
niveau européen c'est pas le choix qui a
été fait par la Commission européenne et
aujourd'hui ce débat est encore en cours
je dirais simplement puisque je ne suis
pas en charge de cette négociation
européenne aujourd'hui qu'il faut à mon
avis préserver deux objectifs d'abord de
la différenciation comme je l'ai dit
les critères les fonctionnements les
niveaux de rémunération des activités de
plateforme ne sont pas tous les mêmes et
puis de la clarté parce que si les
critères de présomption ou de
d'inversion de la présomption de
salariale ne sont pas claires c'est un
des points que la France et d'autres
pays soulève nous serons pas protecteur
bien sûr pour les acteurs économiques
surtout pour les salariés entre
guillemets ou les acteurs qui seraient
requalifiés en salariés parce que chacun
veut savoir évidemment quel cadre social
lui est applicable parlons notre un peu
long sur ce sujet les suivis plutôt dans
des fonctions antérieures je n'en suis
plus directement chargé aujourd'hui je
sais que Olivier du subt le suit
principalement comme historique du
travail de très près et à sans doute
apporter des réponses je voulais juste
finir si vous me permettez sur un point
puisque vous parlez des évolutions du
secteur qui relève lui directement le ma
responsabilité avec la ministre chargée
de handicap c'est la question de
l'accessibilité c'est un vrai sujet de
transformation du secteur du t3p taxi et
VTC et notamment pour les Olympiques et
Paralympiques mais ce sera évidemment un
héritage nous avons mis en place et j'ai
voulu renforcer le dispositif de passage
à 1000 taxis puisque ce sont plutôt les
taxis accessibles
ergo personne à mobilité réduite sur le
périmètre des taxis parisiens
d'ici 2024 et la loi olympique que votre
assemblée a voté récemment que le
Parlement adopté définitivement
récemment permet de délivrer des
autorisations stationnement
supplémentaires dans un but
d'accessibilité conditionné à des
travaux d'accessibilité du véhicule je
ne serai pas trop long sur ce sujet mais
puisque vous parlez des défis du secteur
les transformations du secteur je me
devais aussi de l'évoquer je vous
remercie
merci monsieur le ministre vous l'avez
évoqué dans votre tour d'horizon mais je
voulais vous inviter à peut-être aller
un peu plus dans le détail sur la
question de la lutte contre la fraude on
en a parlé déjà bien sûr avec le
ministre du Travail on sait que les
plateformes de livraison voire VTC ont
pu être condamné en justice à plusieurs
reprises pour pour travailler dissimuler
pour fraude il y a la question notamment
par exemple de la location de compte
parfois des sans-papiers dans le cadre
des plateformes de livraison ce que vous
pouvez nous indiquer vos positions sur
le sujet si vous pensez que le cadre
existant est suffisant vous vous l'avez
évoqué un peu et l'action des différents
ministères ainsi que le vote sur sur la
question
oui peut-être trois points sur ce sujet
pour être un peu plus précis que ce que
j'ai indiqué rapidement en introduction
d'abord il y a des sanctions
administratives ou judiciaires qui
peuvent être prononcés et qui sont
prononcés chaque année à la à l'encontre
des taxis ou des VTC j'ai évoqué le
dispositif de commission locale du
détroit P qui sont présidées par les
préfets départements et ce sont les
services préfectoraux qui sont chargés
d'organiser autant de commissions
disciplinaires que nécessaire en
fonction des faits qui leur sont
remontés ou qu'ils
identifient je prends un exemple sur le
périmètre de la préfecture de police
qui est évidemment le périmètre
principal environ 40% des taxis en
France 16 commissions disciplinaires
taxi VTC ou autre véhicules motorisés
concernés par le transport ont eu lieu
en 2021 et on sanctionnait au total à
l'issue du procédure contradictoires 85
professionnels par des retraits de
cartes pour donner un exemple donc je
parlais de quelques dizaines de cas il y
a des contrôles il y a l'implication par
ces commissions locales est-ce que à mon
avis il faut changer de dispositif je ne
crois pas parce qu'il faut contraindre
le stabiliser peut-être simplement que
les procédures soient plus nombreuses
pour identifier et signifier à ceux qui
seraient tenter de frauder que ces
commissions existent et que les
sanctions sont appliquées je crois que
c'est encore peu connu j'ai évoqué cela
sous la responsabilité du préfet de
police et du ministre de l'intérieur
mais j'en dis un mot l'unité de contrôle
des transports de personnes de la
Préfecture de Police de la direction de
l'ordre public et de la circulation de
la préfecture de police qu'on appelle
souvent donc les Boers il y a une
volonté préfet de police et je crois
vient de l'indiquer ou l'indiquera dans
la journée de mener davantage
d'opérations dites coup de poing pour
avoir des contrôles aussi bien pardon
sur les taxiques sur les VTC vérifiez
que les règles sont appliquées et que
les éventuellement sont sanctionnés ça
peut être des choses très concrètes que
on a sans doute tous vécu comme
utilisateurs ou qui nous sont souvent
signalés notamment par les touristes
l'absence de terminale de paiement
électronique ou pour les VTC par exemple
l'absence de respect de la règle de non
maraude qui est réservé au taxi faut-il
faire évoluer là aussi sur l'équilibre
entre taxi et VTC le cadre réglementaire
qui a été construit par étape et par
itération notamment par les lois
thévenou et ganguillaume je ne le crois
pas quand je reçois et j'ai reçu
plusieurs reprises comme il serait
transports dès le mois de septembre les
représentants professionnels de taxis
les représentants professionnels des VTC
on va revenir peut-être sur d'autres
questions l'examen et autres j'ai le
sentiment que les choses ne sont pas
parfaites mais que le cadre global est
bien posé et que il ne faudrait pas
rouvrir pour le dire un peu crûment la
guerre taxi VTC qui est en fait
retrouver plutôt sur notre apaisement et
d'ailleurs faut-il le préciser des
chauffeurs font parfois les deux
activités puisque c'est possible sous
certaines conditions d'effectuer dans
une même journée ou dans une même
semaine deux types d'activités avec un
même véhicule mais il y a des droits et
des devoirs qui sont différents je crois
que cette équilibre a été construit par
ces deux lois en particulier et par la
l'homme portait par Elisabeth borne sous
le nom de la précédente qui permette par
exemple que quand on est un taxi on a
une prérogative particulière qui est de
pouvoir être ailé et de pouvoir faire de
la maraude mais aussi des contraintes
plus importantes dans l'examen
professionnel ou dans l'achat
historiquement de licence bon alors
qu'un VTC a des obligations initiales
moindres mais droites des droits aussi
qui sont moindres et par exemple
l'interdiction de se faire aimer de
faire de la maraude sont-elles
parfaitement respectées ces règles sans
doute pas c'est un des points que
remonte réglement régulièrement pardon
les fédérations professionnelles et donc
je crois que la concentration qu'on doit
avoir c'est sur l'application de ces
règles plutôt que sur l'évolution ou
alors à la marge du cadre réglementaires
un point important puisque par
différents canaux y compris par des
chartes d'engagement complémentaires des
engagements dont ont été pris par les
plateformes en particulier notamment en
marche 2022 si je ne me trompe pour les
plateformes de chauffeur et de livreurs
et cela apportait aussi ses fruits avec
parfois des effets collatéraux qui ne
sont pas neutres puisque quand les
plateformes ont revu les critères de
dépôt de documents de vérification de
documents d'identité etc ça l'a abouti
on l'a vu à l'automne et à l'hiver
dernier à plusieurs centaines même
parfois plusieurs milliers de
déconnexion de compte ce qui était sur
votre nécessaire puisque ça voulait dire
que c'était des cas
nous respect des règles
sciemment par ignorance des règles par
les chauffeurs et par les livreurs mais
il était important que les plateformes
elles-mêmes accentue le respect de ses
règles un dernier point si vous le
permettez qui élargit un tout petit peu
la focale mais qui me semble aussi très
important c'est que mon prédécesseur
ministre Jebbari et la prédécesseur
d'Isabelle Rome chargé de l'égalité
entre les femmes et les hommes avaient
signé aussi avec les plateformes de VTC
une charte d'engagement sur la lutte
contre les violences sexuelles sexistes
c'est une autre forme
de règles et d'encadrement avec des
actions du type bouton d'alerte par
exemple qui se mettent en place et qui
je vais être très honnête doivent être
mieux appliquées et renforcés et que je
souhaite aussi appliquer au taxi comme
quoi on peut prendre des bonnes
pratiques dans une partie du secteur et
les transposer dans le reste du secteur
des 3P j'ai réuni un comité de lutte
contre les violences sexuelles et
sexistes il y a quelques jours et cet
engagement a été confirmé à la fois par
les plateformes de VTC et par les
organisations représentatives des taxis
merci moi j'ai eu une autre question je
voulais profiter notamment de votre
expérience aux Affaires européennes on a
souvent comme sur d'autres sujets sur ce
débat une approche très insulaire or les
questions que nous posons sur
l'encadrement sur l'équilibre trouver
entre les VTC les taxis entre
l'innovation et la protection sociale
sont évidemment des questions qui ont
été posées dans toutes les grandes
économies et qui ont vu arriver ces
nouveaux phénomènes d'ailleurs vous avez
souligné juste dit que toujours
aujourd'hui il y a à Paris une demande
une offre par habitant de VTC ou taxi
qui reste inférieur quand même aux
villes grandes villes touristiques
comparable c'était naturellement le cas
aussi bien sûr avant l'arrivée des VTC
ce qui explique d'ailleurs qu'il n'y a
pas eu comme vous l'avez signer dans
votre introduction des faits d'éviction
de remplacement mais au contraire un
marché aujourd'hui et qui est neuf plus
importante y compris au niveau des taxis
qui sont plus nombreux aujourd'hui qui
ne l'était il y a une dizaine d'années
est-ce que vous pouvez juste nous nous
esquisser la façon dont la France se
compare par rapport à ses principaux
partenaires européens et la façon
d’ailleurs dont ça se transpose dans le
débat actuel sur la directive sur cette
question de l'encadrement de la
régulation des VTC des relations entre
ces deux secteurs et
voir d'ailleurs s'il y a des exemples
contre-exemples que nous pourrions
suivre sur les dispositifs
merci alors ma connaissance les éléments
de comparaison sont encore peu fragiles
à la fois parce que la tendance est
récente et parce que les périmètres ou
les régulations ne sont pas exactement
les mêmes d'un pays à l'autre ou d'une
grande capitale à l'autre ce qu'on
constate c'est que dans toutes les
grandes capitales ce qu'on appelle chez
nous les VTC ce sont développés depuis
le milieu des années 2000 parce que au
départ la technologie des applications
et donc les plateformes de mise en
relation dans d'autres domaines aussi ce
sont développés et donc on constate
cette tendance dans toutes les grandes
capitales européennes je ne sais pas si
c'est toujours le cas mais je sais qu'il
y a encore quelques mois grande
plateforme de chauffeurs bien connu
indiquait que la France est Paris en
particulier était son deuxième marché
urbain mondial et le premier or des
États-Unis ce qui en tout cas signifie
je sais pas si c'est encore le cas
l'heure où nous parlons mais ce qui en
tout cas signifie qu'il y avait sans
doute une place à prendre
pour compléter une offre de transport et
je le redis quand je regarde les
chiffres parisiens et je n'ai pas
connaissance de contre-exemple européen
ou l'exemple différents au niveau
européen c'est qu'il n'y a pas eu de
baisse au contraire du nombre de
licences de taxi et que on a encore sans
doute de la place pour offrir plus de
transports
dans les années qui viennent en France
sur les deux volets à la fois les VTC et
les taxis et tous les pays européens ont
cherché progressivement une régulation
elle s'est faite par deux types
d'actions soit par des règles loi ou
règlement soit par des décisions de
justice notamment sur le volet social
que vous avez évoqué c'est des décisions
de justice je prends l'Europe au sens
large hors de l'Union Européenne au
Royaume-Uni en Espagne qui ont parfois
abouti à reconnaître des cas de salariat
qui n'ont pas forcément eu un effet
généralisateur c'est à dire ça pas
abouti à ce que le salariat soit
toujours la règle et peu de pays pour
l'avoir vécu directement avec porté
l'idée d'une régulation européenne et
même je le dis sans arrogance française
mais avec une conviction et c'était la
réalité ce sont
des élus français y compris d'ailleurs
au Parlement européen mais le
gouvernement français au Conseil qui a
porté l'idée encore une fois qu'il y ait
justement pour éviter un morcellement
pour éviter des directions différentes
pour éviter des cadres plus ou moins
protecteurs d'un pays à l'autre et des
comparaisons qui ne sont jamais bonnes
qu'on est ce cadre commun européen
ensuite on peut discuter de savoir si il
faut une présomption générale de
salariat s'il faut une présomption de
salariés avec des critères comme c'est
ce qui semble c'est ce qui sait au
conseil s'il faut un cadre de régulation
Adobe comme nous l'avons commencé au
niveau national à ma connaissance le
modèle que nous avons développé sur les
relations sociales je disais par étape
ou être 2016 ordonnance de 2021
création de l'art création d'un cadre de
dialogue social et de représentativité
est unique et je pense qu'il doit être
préservé ou renforcée
oui merci merci Monsieur le monsieur le
ministre vous laissez sous-entendre en
fait enfin même vous dites clairement
que finalement c'était la France qui
souhaitait à tout prix un texte et
quelque part c'est la France qui a
impulsé le travail
de l'Union européenne sur sur cette
question de régulation des relations des
travailleurs des plateformes mais est-ce
que la France n'était pas plutôt en
défense non pas d'un texte sur les
travailleurs des plateformes qu'on a
aujourd'hui mais vous les non pas une
directive en tant que tel mais une ligne
directrice sous l'angle plutôt des de
des règles de la concurrence et pas de
l'article 153 du du Traité du TFUE c'est
à dire sur les droits des dérangés les
droits des travailleurs pardon
excusez-moi
parce qu'en fait
la position de la France si je comprends
pas de la lecture que j'en ai eu c'est
qu'elle voulait à la fois donner le
droit aux indépendants de pouvoir
aborder un dialogue social sans pouvoir
être accusé de déroger aux règles de la
concurrence et de l'entente et qui avait
de fait une volonté de finalement de
permettre par le biais du dialogue
social d'éviter toute requalification ça
salarié tout en reconnaissant enfin tout
en imposant qu'on était dans des
relations commerciales et sans se mettre
en porte-à-faux des règles commerciales
je sais pas si vous comprenez ce que je
veux dire mais il me semble que le 15
décembre 2021 à Strasbourg vous êtes à
l'époque juste avant la présidente
française de l'Union européenne
secrétaire d'État à l'Europe et vous
assumez d'ailleurs avoir un désaccord
avec la proposition de la Commission
européenne et il me semble que les
travaux enfin dans ce cas la feuille de
route de la Commission européenne sur
une directive concernant les relations
les travailleurs des plateformes mais
bien antérieurs à la PFE
puisque c'est madame vanderlione qui qui
dansait déjà le le
lancer le travail
donc je voudrais aussi vous interroger
sur le fait que l'Union européenne dans
son étude d'impact a d'ailleurs montré
que
dans une estimation qui aurait 28
millions de de travailleurs de
plateformes il y en aurait au moins 5
millions qui seraient requalifiés en
salariés avec la démarche de la
directive présomption de salariat et
qu'il s'agirait surtout des livreurs de
repas et des chauffeurs VTC
j'ai bien
j'ai bien pris note de vos propos tout à
l'heure et vous dites que il faut
absolument protéger les vrais
indépendants et sanctionner les abus de
faux indépendants alors êtes-vous
favorable à la requalification salariée
maintenant que vous êtes ministre de
transport de l'ensemble des chauffeurs
VTC puisque toutes les décisions de
justice attestent bien qu'ils sont dans
une dans un lien de subordination que
dans son étude d'impact la Commission
européenne dit bien qu'il faudrait les
requalifier en salariés ou bien
êtes-vous en totale désaccord finalement
avec la démarche de l'Union européenne
comme vous l'avez exprimé le 15 décembre
2021 à Strasbourg et vous vantez comme
Monsieur du soft la démarche de la
France d'instaurer un dialogue social
est-ce qu'au nom de ce dialogue social
vous avez convoqué une réunion
extraordinaire de l'ARPE pour que il y
ait un débat
de l'art dans l'ARPE au sein de l'art
pas sorti d'un vote sur la position
devrait défendre la France sur cette
directive présente sur un préalable de
salariat
sachez que j'ai demandé à votre
homologue ministre du Travail s'il avait
concerté
l'ensemble des organisations les
confédérations syndicales à laquelle moi
j'ai écrit et qui m'ont répondu toutes
qu'en fait elle n'avait pas été
sollicité par le gouvernement pour
s'enquérir de leur position vis-à-vis de
cette directive présente de salariat et
vous en tant que ministre que
pensez-vous de la demande que je porte à
la fois en tant que que
[Musique]
avec le groupe la France insoumise mais
toutes les composantes tous les groupes
politiques de la nupes qu'il y ait bien
un débat assorti d'un vote à l'Assemblée
nationale au nom de l'article 50 alinéa
1 de la Constitution
concernant cette directive présomption
de salariat européenne afin qu'on sache
ce que la France défend
merci beaucoup madame rapporteur et
beaucoup de choses pas sur leur tout
compris mais je vais essayer de d'être
le plus précis possible dans mes
éléments de réponse à vos différentes
questions d'abord sur le volet européen
je n'ai pas dit que c'était au moment de
la présidence française de l'Union
européenne commençait au 1er janvier
2022 que le débat avait commencé sur la
question d'une directive en effet cette
directive ce projet de directive avait
déjà été déposé à ce moment-là ce que
j'ai dit c'est qu'en revanche dans cette
perspective notamment de la présidence
française de l'Union européenne qui
était importante pour nous mais plus
largement et on fait des faits bien
avant je le répète la France avait
défendu oui l'idée qu'il y a un texte
européen sur la régulation des
plateformes et quand je dis un texte
c'est bien un texte législatif un texte
à valeur imposé contraignante ça peut
être une directive ou un règlement je
crois que nous n'avions pas formulé à ma
connaissance une préférence pour l'un ou
pour l'autre mais en revanche une
préférence très claire pour l'existence
d'un texte
par rapport à de simples recommandations
ligne directrice indication ou autres
possibilités européennes ça c'est très
clair c'est facile vous avez l'occasion
d'éditionner le commissaire Schmitt
Nicolas Schmitt commissaire à l'emploi
et je sais pas si vous avez bloqué cette
question précise pas parler à sa place
mais je crois qu'il ne démonterait pas
l'engagement de la France que nous avons
porté non pour demander un texte
européen sur le volet social premier
point deuxième point sur le contenu du
texte c'est pas un scoop et je l'assume
parfaitement je ne suis plus en charge
de cette négociation mais j'ai été parti
prenante de ces épisodes précédents si
je puis dire comme secrétaire d'État aux
Affaires européennes oui nous avons
défendu l'idée qu'il fallait un texte
européen commun en dur mais que la
présomption généralisée de salariat
n'était selon nous par la voie la
protectrice je ne l'ai jamais caché je
crois que vous avez vous allez
auditionner la députée européenne madame
lelechidy qui s'est beaucoup impliqué
je vous salue madame européenne pardon
je n'avais pas que vous étiez dans la
salle ça tombe bien je crois que vous
pouvez le dire vous pourriez le dire en
toute transparence nous avons eu ces
échanges en partageant l'idée je crois
que il fallait une régulation et une
régulation européenne et j'ai défendu
moi sans le cacher l'idée que la voix
d'un cadre social addock était me
semble-t-il la meilleure voie pour
avancer dans le sillage de ce que nous
défendions au niveau français c'est
assez cohérent vous en conviendrez
ensuite est-ce qu'il faut différencier
par type de profession puisque dans le
secteur il y a des choses différentes
des situations différentes ce qu'on est
livreur je ne citerai pas de marque
enfin on voit bien dans nos villes
conducteur VTC ou qu'on travaille pour
d'autres plateformes oui ça ne me
choquerait pas qu'il y ait des exigences
différentes d'ailleurs la justice a eu à
connaître de cas notamment sur une
grande plateforme bien connue où elle a
constaté que déjà dans le droit français
dans certains cas où dans certaines
conditions étaient réunies les critères
du salariat des facto bon et donc est-ce
qu'il faut prévoir par exemple plus en
charge directement de ce dossier mais
des règles plus protectrices pour les
chauffeurs VTC ou pour les livreurs
parce qu'ils sont contenus de la taille
des plateformes compte tenu de
développement du secteur en général des
acteurs très récurrents très réguliers
voire complètement stable de tel ou
telle plateforme ça ne me choquerait pas
qui est des règles spécifiques je vous
le dis aussi les règles européennes on
les discute on défend cette position
d'avoir un cadre différencié et Haddock
comme il se doit si la directive quand
la directive sera adoptée ce que je
souhaite est-ce que le gouvernement
défend bien nous appliquerons les règles
européennes quelle qu'elle soit il y a
une discussion entre le Parlement
européen et le Conseil aujourd'hui sur
la convocation de l'ARPE
il me semble pas que ce soit dans ce
cadre là pas exactement compris qu'elle
était l'idée mais que on ferait
législation si le Parlement souhaite se
saisir ou voter d'une législation soit
en transposition de la directive dans
quelques mois sans doute soit pour
prendre les devants sur tel ou tel
élément de régulation supplémentaire
notamment sur l'encadrement de
l'indépendance ou aller un grand plus
loin ça je crois que ça ne relève pas de
l'ARPE des missions de l'arbre le
définir les missions de l'arbre sont
ciblées limités elles lisent à permettre
le dialogue social c'est le cadre que
nous avons retenu entre les
représentants des employeurs et
désormais les représentants élus des
travailleurs des plateformes
donc je crois que c'est pas l'ARPE de ce
substituer ni à une négociation
européenne menée par le Parlement
européen et le Conseil ni au travail
parlementaire et si il y a des modalités
de consultation que le Parlement
souhaite organiser pour nourrir ses
travaux comme cette commission est
peut-être d'autres c'est bien sûr à vous
de le terminer quand à l'article 50-1
c'est à la fois les choix parlementaires
et gouvernementaux je suis en charge
directement de ce dossier donc vous
permettrez que je ne préjugue pas de la
position sur ce sujet mais je crois que
vous aurez l'occasion et je ne doute pas
que vous poser la question d'interroger
la première ministre
oui alors écoutez moi je ne critique pas
le fait que votre ligne soit cohérente
je la trouve extrêmement cohérente mais
par ailleurs elle correspond totalement
à la cohérence qui a pu défendre
uber Hubert dans son better deal
et dans les tribunes que Hubert a pu
transmettre à la presse et qui date
notamment
de du 16 février 2021 donc avant la
création de l'arbre mais au moment aussi
où tout cela se discutait
la stratégie du Berre c'est clairement
de dire il faut défendre un dialogue
social et permettre des nouveaux droits
sociaux pour les travailleurs des
plateformes bon vous me direz qui peut
être contre qu'il y a un dialogue social
qui peut être opposé au dialogue social
et aux droits sociaux mais la stratégie
d'Uber c'est bien de faire en sorte
qu'il y a un dialogue social est droits
sociaux pour se soustraire de toute
requalification salariée et faire en
sorte qu'on soit simplement sur la mise
en relation de travailleurs indépendants
et de clientèle pour un service et donc
disposition de la France que vous
rappelez avec l'ensemble de vos termes
comme la fait monsieur du soft dans une
totale cohérence finalement revient à
défendre la position de la plateforme
uber et je trouve quand même hallucinant
de dire que nous sommes favorables un
dialogue social le dialogue social de
l'art peut parler de tout sauf de la
question du statut qu'est la question
fondamentale donc les travailleurs des
plateformes par le biais de leur
représentant peuvent à l'ARP parler de
la question des tarifs par les la
question d'un certain nombre de droits
sociaux mais ne peuvent pas parler du
statut donc je trouve ça étonnant mais
j'ai néanmoins d'autres questions à vous
poser vous avez
abordé la question des contrôles et des
Bauer vous avez parlé de la question de
l'équilibre entre taxi VTC monsieur le
ministre et transport que pouvez-vous
dire sur le fait que finalement
aujourd'hui soyons francs la loi tu es
venue et la loi grand Guillaume ne sont
pas pleinement appliquées
puisque la loi thévenou et la loi grand
Guillaume sont censés notamment
interdire la maraude électronique exiger
un retour au garage instaurer une
véritable data
est-ce que vous estimez que cette loi
est pleinement appliquée première
question vous avez dit que vous
souhaitiez en renforcer les moyens de
contrôle et c'est vrai que ce secteur de
plateforme c'est tellement précarisé
paupérisé engendrant ou si une certaine
précarisation à des taxis qu'on a une
multiplication pratique illégale et
notamment les pratiques de racolage et
d'arnaque aux alentours de gare et
d'aéroport et que il urgent de
d'augmenter les effectifs des Bauer pas
simplement sur sur l'Île-de-France mais
aussi sur les grands sur l'ensemble des
grands métropoles mais vous êtes
d'accord que les lois sont faites pour
être appliquées comment le gouvernement
entend le faire dernière chose
vous avez parlé des commissions locales
de transport de particuliers de
personnes
vous avez aussi normalement un
observatoire national des transports
publics particuliers de personnes qui
devaient développer dans tous les
départements est-ce que c'est développé
dans tous les départements est-ce que il
disposent bien de toutes les données par
département car vous avez donné les
données
concernant le nombre de VTC mais pour
les chaînes nationales or c'est à
l'échelle de chaque département qui sont
nécessaires y a-t-il eu des rapports
depuis 2018 de ces observatoires de
cette observatoire national et qui
permet justement d'évaluer l'évolution
du nombre de taxis de VTC et de la
demande et dernière question vous avez
fait une référence aux Jeux olympiques
et à l'augmentation des licences
pour notamment les personnes à mobilité
réduite vous vous souvenez bien que
lorsqu'il y a eu le début du démarrage
du Berre et des et des mobilisations des
taxis contre contre les vétés ou plutôt
contre l'ubérisation le sujet souvent
qui était mis en avant c'est il faut
absolument une disruption pour
concurrencer le mot Paul des taxis et
des grands de la G7 et le président a
juste titre dans une dans une
audriedition du président du directeur
de la G7 a rappelé aussi les profits
engranger par par la G7 sur ce secteur
dès lors pourquoi avoir accordé 500
licences aux grandes sociétés taxi donc
en premier lieu certainement la G7 et
seulement 150 au locataire gérant donc
au futur artisans alors que précisément
Emmanuel Macron et ceux qui étaient
proches de lui à l'époque défendait à
l'ubérisation pour créer une concurrence
saine dans le secteur des taxis or là on
renforce les grandes entreprises à la
part à la place des artisans
merci madame le rapporteur surpris que
vous n'enviez pas plutôt à cette idée
qu'il y a évidemment
c'est insinuation sur laquelle toute la
politique menée sera la politique du
beurre moi j'ai pas suivi tout le
dossier je vais être très clair je ne
crois pas que les lois thévenouées grand
Guillaume étaient le souhait du beurre
je crois pas que la directive était le
souhait du beurre moi j'étais pas en
charge de cette question enfin je pense
que vous aurez du mal à le démontrer et
je pense pas que l'idée d'avoir une
régulation européenne et je le maintiens
que peu de pays même aucun pays ne
souhaitait au départ que la Commission
elle-même le souhaitait pas au départ et
sans l'action de la France il n'y aurait
pas se débat sur la directive on peut
avoir un débat sur le contenu il y aura
pas de débat sur la directive sans
l'action de la France je le maintiens y
compris des gouvernements qui associent
des parties de gauche parfois d'extrême
gauche dans leur propre camp c'est la
France qui a défendu cela je le
maintiens et je l'assume parfaitement
qu'on est une volonté qui soit pas
l'interdiction qui soit pas
l'empêchement des grandes plateformes
quel que soit d'ailleurs la nationalité
mais qui soit des exigences renforcées
on peut avoir un débat parce que il y a
pas de monopole du coeur ou du social
sur la façon efficace de protéger les
droits des travailleurs vous m'avez
interrogé j'ai été clair est-ce qu'il
faut sans doute des obligations
supplémentaires dans le secteur des
livreurs dans le secteur des chauffeurs
oui je le crois et d'ailleurs la justice
a commencé en application de notre droit
existant à l'exiger dans un certain
nombre de cas et que le Parlement s'en
en parle même pas ne mettons pas de
soupçon là où il y en a pas l'ARPE c'est
pas elle qui définit les statuts c'est
elle qui définit la loi c'est pas si
vous vous le Parlement décide c'est pas
la position que je déforme mais si le
Parlement décidait de voter le salariat
généralisé c'est pas l'arbre qui va être
contre ou être pour l'art est un
établissement public qui a une mission
et un principe de spécialité qui est
d'organiser le dialogue social si on
veut changer de modèle j'ai expliqué les
raisons pour lesquelles je crois que le
modèle actuel porte ses fruits et permet
des accords et d'ailleurs je les redis
il y a encore des accords ambitieux qui
sont en cours qui étaient pas
franchement la volonté des plateformes
au départ qui vont renforcer je crois le
minimum de rémunération des chauffeurs
et je le souhaite bien si on change des
modèles et qu'on veut plus de l'art et
qu'on veut autre chose c'est au
Parlement souverain dans des idées ou
aux règles européennes et au Parlement
européen dans décidé c'est pas le
établissement public qui va choisir ses
missions et sa spécialité ce serait une
drôle de conception non mais ce serait
une drôle de conception des choses et
voilà mais non mais pour qu'il y ait pas
de l'ambiguïté sur ce que peut faire
l'ARP ou ce que ne peut pas faire est-ce
que les lois devenu et grand Guillaume
en particulier sont bien impliqués oui
je crois qu'elles sont appliquées les
services de mon ministère le cas échéant
du ministère de l'Intérieur un certain
nombre de cas notamment sous l'autorité
du préfet de police les fonds respectés
est-ce que comme toute loi ça veut dire
qu'il y a zéro abus et que 100% des cas
de fraude ou de non-respect des règles
on va dire comme ça sont
identifiés sanctionnés sans doute pas
bon est-ce qu'il faut renforcer les
effectifs des Bauer c'est pas moi qui en
Suisse décisionnaires mais je crois
pouvoir dire je sais pas si vous avez
l'occasion d'interroger Laurent Lunel se
préfet de police que c'est bien la
direction qui est prise et que le préfet
de police en a fait en effet
sous-entation du milieu intérieur et de
moi-même une priorité qui vaut
d'ailleurs pour les VTC comme pour les
taxis puisque ces deux professions sont
soumises à des règles un peu différentes
mais qui importante et pour tout vous
dire puisque j'ai réuni à plusieurs
reprises les représentants
professionnels des taxis comme des VTC
c'est ma responsabilité de ministre des
Transports oui il y a notamment de la
part des taxis des demandes qu'on
applique mieux qu'on sanctionne plus
qu'on renforce la vérification des
règles sur le respect de la maraude qui
est leur prérogative est pas celle des
VTC et donc c'est aussi une des missions
des Bauer notamment et c'est toujours la
même chose si on veut que la loi soit
mieux respectée il faut un effet des
effectifs et des sanctions exemplaires
sur les autorisations de stationnement
pardon c'est un débat très intéressant
pour ça que j'avais spontanément parlé
de l'accessibilité qu'est-ce qu'on a
fait j'étais pas en responsabilité mais
je m'inscris dans cette continuité pour
renforcer l'accessibilité des véhicules
PMR personne en fauteuil et personne à
mobilité réduite on a mis en place une
aide
une aide à la transformation
l'acquisition le nouveau véhicule pour
qu'il soit mis en accessibilité cette
aide est réservée par décret au taxi et
je n'ai pas changé ce cadre là c'est
réservé au taxi et notamment au taxi
individuel il y a pas de changement sur
les autorisations etc qu'est-ce que j'ai
constaté en arrivant en mystère et
transport c'est que nous avions fixé un
objectif qu'on peut partager de mille
taxi PMR pour donner un ordre de
grandeur c'est 5 fois plus
qu'aujourd'hui dans les taxis parisiens
en région parisienne quand on était pas
du tout à cet objectif et pas du tout
sur la trajectoire de cet objectif et
donc il y avait plusieurs outils et j'ai
proposé avec la Ministre chargée des
Jeux olympiques et paralympiques que on
est spécifiquement
spécifiquement sur la question de
l'accessibilité en effet et je l'assume
parfaitement des possibilités d'octroyer
des licences supplémentaires pas
seulement mais aussi à des personnes
morales sous strictes conditions que ce
soit pour acheter des véhicules pourquoi
je vais vous le dire très franchement
parce que ceux qu'on la capacité de
commander rapidement ici les Jeux
Olympiques et massivement des véhicules
des véhicules accessibles au PMR ce sont
en effet plutôt des sociétés plutôt que
des taxis individuels mais comme je
souhaite le préfet de police le met en
oeuvre que on exclut pas les taxis
individuels des artisans taxi de ce
geste complémentaire il y a en effet 500
licences et transparent qui sont
accordés sur la base de la loi olympique
qui a été votée par le Parlement je n'ai
pas caché ce point devant le Sénat je
peux l'occasion d'en parler devant
l'Assemblée nationale où on exprimerait
c'est Amélie Willi à Castera qu'il a
fait mais nous avons été très clair sur
le fait je crois que c'était l'article 8
du projet de loi qui permet ces licences
supplémentaires pour les personnes
morales donc très clair et d'ailleurs je
n'ai pas eu l'occasion dans les battre
avec vous même à l'Assemblée nationale
mais la gauche est notoriale a été je
crois convaincue par cet argument au nom
de la mise en accessibilité de cette
priorité assumée vous dire on a si je
vous écoute beaucoup d'amis madame la
rapporteur puisque on est soi-disant les
acteurs
mettant en place les recommandations
d'une plateforme comme uber et en même
temps les amis de la G7 alors vous avez
dit vous-même d'ailleurs que il
défendait des positions contradictoires
comme quoi je crois qu'on essaie de
défendre une position d'intérêt général
on peut avoir les différences d'opinions
mais d'intérêt général sur les cas qui
sont les nôtres développer la
concurrence oui je l'assume et je pense
qu'il était important d'avoir avec un
encadrement législatif réglementaire des
VTC qui se développent et des priorités
des carbonations accessibilité qui
nécessitent de recourir aussi au taxi
car les armes sont pas les ennemis des
autres
oui merci monsieur le Président Monsieur
le Ministre en début de d'audition vous
avez employé l'expression de
développement bénéfique vous évoquiez je
pense par cette expression la
satisfaction de l'offre mais
quel coût social
pour qu'elle couche sociale car ce que
l'on appelle avec le recul la
plateformeisation ou l'ubérisation
c'est cependant la généralisation de
toutes les mauvaises pratiques en droit
du travail permettez-moi dans citer
quelques-unes mais je ne suis pas
exhaustive d'abord le travail dissimulé
généralisé parce que l'on peut
considérer quand l'état des
jurisprudences notamment de la chambre
sociale de la Cour de cassation toutes
les plateformes employeurs connaissent
le statut et le lien de subordination
qu'elles imposent et tombe sur le coup
du travail dissimulé tel qu'il est prévu
par l'article 82 23 c'est rien du Code
du travail l'emploi de salariés en
situation irrégulière c'est la
problématique des faux comptes et votre
prédécesseur ce matin ministre du
Travail à reconnu l'impuissance des
pouvoirs publics à lutter contre ces
faux comptes c'est le contournement des
règles du travail du dimanche du travail
de nuit du repos compensateur qui
renvoie aux problématiques de la
sécurité au travail qui est une
obligation de résultats qui pèse
normalement sur les employeurs
c'est des cotisations sociales par
définition et du dé et c'est aussi un
instrument de fraude fiscale et nous
avons évoqué les problématiques des
terminaux de paiement et ou plutôt de
l'absence des terminaux de paiement dans
nombreux véhicules les travailleurs sont
forcément
victimes et durablement victime de ces
mauvaises pratiques du travail donc j'en
viens
à deux questions si vous me le permettez
la première
pensez-vous monsieur le ministre en
matière d'acquis sociaux de protection
des travailleurs de respect du Code du
travail on puisse employer le terme de
développement bénéfique et ma deuxième
question
qui fait écho aux propos de Madame la
rapporteur c'est la troisième voie ce
statut Haddock que l'on voit se dessiner
et qui sont souhaités par beaucoup de
plateformes n'est-ce pas quand même à
terme l'institutionnalisation de ces
mauvaises pratiques qui
sont révélés suite à de nombreuses
décennies de contentieux et de syndicale
je vais vous proposer qu'on prenne tout
de suite monsieur zgins qui madame
rouleau et comme ça on laissera le
ministre répondre rapidement puisqu'on
doit passer après à l'audition de la
première ministre
merci monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Ministre merci pour votre présence une
question un petit peu complémentaire
depuis la mise en place de de nouveaux
statuts notamment de VTC les chiffres de
l'Insee montre clairement un
développement une forte hausse de
l'activité de transport de personnes
bon pérenniser ce développement le
rendre plus durable sur les plans social
économiques paraît aujourd'hui une
nécessité pour consolider ce secteur on
a auditionné également des représentants
de nouveaux modèles de plateforme plus
coopératives
voilà quel est votre avis sur sur cette
solution là
potentielle et en général puisqu'on est
dans une commission d'enquête où nous
devons être prospectif également sur
l'amélioration de de ce secteur
d'activité en particulier sur l'aspect
transport puisque ça relève de vos
compétences quelle
suggestion pourriez-vous quasi
pourriez-vous
transmettre à notre commission sur ces
sujets sur ce sujet merci
même rouleau je sais pas je crois que
vous aviez une question
merci oui monsieur le ministre
je voulais aussi à la suite de mon
collègue Félice Philippe Shrek revenir
sur les propos que vous avez eu vous
avez dit tout à l'heure
on préfère un cadre social à d'autres ce
sont vos termes et juste avant vous
disiez que la France justement avait été
à l'initiative en fait
souhaiter une directive et vous avez
rappelé que l'objectif à ce moment là
c'était la différenciation d'une part et
la clarté donc si vous souhaitez aussi
un statut social Haddock c'est un petit
peu peut-être contradictoire avec ce
souci cet objectif de clarté et surtout
je voulais savoir ce que vous entendiez
par là est-ce que le cadre social
Hadoque c'est finalement uniquement le
dialogue social et des conventions au
cas par cas et donc de la jurisprudence
ou alors est-ce qu'on peut envisager une
traduction législative de ce cadre
Haddock de cette ouverture parce que
j'imagine que c'est peut-être ça entre
le statut du salarié et le statut de
l'indépendant une troisième voie
qu'est-ce que c'est ce statut social
Haddock et est-ce que on peut imaginer
qu'il y aurait une traduction
législative au moins sur certains points
je vous remercie monsieur
merci beaucoup je vais essayer de
répondre brièvement mais néanmoins
précisément d'abord monsieur Shrek
j'ai parlé d'un bénéfice sur un point
c'est que l'offre s'est développée et
les 40.000 on va prendre ce chiffre là
des 40000 chauffeurs actifs en
particulier
je pense que c'était un certain nombre
de cas les gens qui n'avaient pas
d'emploi du tout
on est encore de recul sur ce sujet je
vais être très clair aussi ce qu'on
appelle la réalité très différentes
justement mais ce qu'on appelle
uberisation c'est ni mon rêve ni mon
projet ce que je veux dire par là c'est
que il faut être très clair je crois
quand on est en responsabilité qu'est-ce
qu'on fait est-ce qu'on interdit les
plateformes ou est-ce qu'on régule les
plateformes
et aucun pays européen n'a proposé
d'ailleurs ni dans son propre périmètre
ni au niveau de l'Union européenne des
interdictions et d'ailleurs qu'est-ce
qui se passerait si on cherchait je
crois pour être décréter par règlement
par la loi que il y a plus de plateforme
ou dans certains secteurs c'est interdit
d'opérer par plateforme je crois que
c'est ce qu'on appelle la prohibition il
se placerait exactement ce que vous
dénoncez à juste titre c'est-à-dire du
travail dissimulé parce que l'outil
technique des applications il y a rien
de plus facile à développer donc je
crois que c'est pas facile aucun pays
n'a trouvé complètement la clé il y a
des positions politiques différentes
mais tous essaient de réguler notamment
en Europe pour que il y ait un cadre
social je vais y revenir madame la
députée qui est un cadre social qui
s'applique et il y a des débats et des
bas sincères si je puis dire sur la
présomption de salariat sur la
présomption générale de salariats sur la
critérisation pour appliquer ou pas
cette présomption pour la différencier
en fonction de tel ou tel secteur un pas
sur tous les points la fraude fiscale il
faut évidemment la combattre elle est
pas propre à ces secteurs où je vais
être très clair
est-ce que on était dans un secteur où
il y avait zéro problème et zéro fraude
je parle du t3p avant l'arrivée des VTC
est-ce que on avait partout les
terminaux de paiement électronique qui
permettaient de s'assurer que le
consommateur et l'usagé était bien servi
que on retraçait tous les frais
financiers je suis pas certain est-ce
que l'arrivée des VTC a aussi permis au
législateur d'ailleurs d'appliquer des
règles nouvelles qui bénéficient à tout
le secteur oui je crois est-ce que le
service est meilleur oui je crois est-ce
que la régulation est renforcée oui je
crois est-ce qu'il faut aller plus loin
oui je le crois aussi et on va être très
honnête le travail au noir le travail
dissimulé ce n'est pas propre à ce
secteur là et les secteurs si je peux
dire bien plus traditionnel qu'on n'a
pas interdit comme le bâtiment est très
haut public on sait que les choses
existent aussi qu'il faut les renforcer
par les moyens d'inspection du travail
par des sanctions exemplaires etc donc
oui bien sûr il faut organiser réguler
secteur et nous sommes sans doute qu'à
mi-chemin de ce travail de régulation
nationale et européen donc c'est dans ce
sens là que j'ai dit qu'il y avait un
service qui s'était développé et je
crois améliorer mais bien sûr une
protection sociale je vais dire de
manière générique à apporter et on n'est
pas encore au bout de cette logique qui
vous permettait je vais ainsi
passer la question d'un rouleau et je
reviendrai à votre question monsieur le
député
quand j'ai parlé de différenciation et
de clarté clarté ça veut simplement dire
que ceux qui sont concernés par les
règles les plateformes comme acteur
économiques surtout les livreurs
chauffeurs ou autres travailleurs des
plateformes comme bénéficiaire de cette
protection il faut qu'il comprenne
comment ça s'applique si la directive
est peu compréhensible pour le dire
comme ça parce que les critères sont
trop nombreux est-ce qu'ils vont être
appliqués du coup différemment d'un pays
à l'autre je crois qu'on aura pas une
protection satisfaisante il faudra
remettre l'ouvrage sur le métier c'est
dans ce sens là et différenciation parce
que oui je l'assume je le redis en
réponse à la question madame la
rapporteur que la question des livreurs
et la question des chauffeurs et sans
doute un secteur ou socialement il faut
les plus protectrices que dans d'autres
domaines où il y a des centaines de
plateformes dans des milliers de
plateforme qui sont une réalité très
disparate le chauffeur uber puisque vous
avez utilisé cette plateforme ou le
livreur de livres ou oui ils doivent
faire l'objet d'une protection je pense
renforcée à l'évidence vous me parliez
madame la députée d'un cadre social
aussi la doc ça veut pas dire qu'elle
remue ça veut pas dire simplement des
chars les discussions au coin du feu
d'ailleurs je dis de l'Assemblée
nationale tout cela résulte depuis loi
la loi de 2016 qui a créé la cotisation
en matière d'accident du travail la loi
de financement de la sécurité sociale
qui depuis 2023 a créé une protection
sociale complémentaire une ordonnance et
une loi qui avait été portée à l'époque
par Elisabeth borne qui a permis
d'organiser ce dialogue social
c'est-à-dire que social il vient pas
spontanément la création de l'arbre
c'est de législateur qu'il a voulu et le
gouvernement qui l'a mise en place donc
cadre social Haddock ne veut pas dire
que les choses sont
contournables légères ou à la carte ou à
la demande je précise aussi j'ai eu
l'occasion de le dire que parmi les
acteurs européens qui avaient défendu
l'idée de règle Haddock il y a la
Confédération européenne des syndicats
il y a la Confédération européenne des
syndicats présidé par le secrétaire
général de la CFDT qui ne demandait pas
ma connaissance une présomption générale
de salariat et je bosse pas qu'on puisse
reprocher au syndicat européen morme la
Confédération Européenne des syndicale
il y avait des débats entre eux
pourraient peut-être transparent mais de
ne pas se préoccuper de la protection
des chauffeurs des livreurs et des
autres travailleurs de plateformes
dernier point pour répondre à Monsieur
le Député de guinski
oui il y a sans doute je crois que les
directeur général du travail a donné
cette indication
actif plus de 100 000 travailleurs des
plateformes en général avec des
situations là encore très différentes et
oui je le maintiens je crois que la
plateforme c'est à dire une application
qui permet de mettre en relation des
personnes pour le faire de manière très
courte il y a beaucoup d'activités
différentes quand vous êtes un
prestataire informatique très qualifié
vous n'avez pas tout à fait les mêmes
enjeux de rémunération à garantir et à
augmenter de droits sociaux à sécuriser
que
un livreur ou un chauffeur qui lui en
effet ou elle mérite une protection
renforcée et je le redis je pense nous
ne sommes pas tout à fait au bout du
cadre législatif réglementaire et
européen que nous devons appliquer je
comprends aussi que c'est l'un des
objets espérant avoir pu contribuer à
l'éclairer du travail de votre
commission monsieur le Président madame
le rapporteur
je suis vraiment désolé parce que je
sais qu'on a une question supplémentaire
monsieur caravane mais si vous mixerez
puisqu'on a la première minute je crois
qu'il y a tant déjà donc
vous serez pour lui poser la question je
vais suspendre maintenant monsieur le
ministre je vous remercie de votre
disponibilité et de vos réponses à la
commission d'enquête si d'ailleurs je
précise que nous pouvons aussi vous
transmettre par voie écrite les
questions supplémentaires que nous
auront peut-être d'ailleurs des demandes
de documents mais dans l'intervalle je
vous remercie et je vous souhaite une
excellente journée je vous remercie